pensemos en como una opción de venta
puede darnos un apalancamiento en un
aspecto negativo o bien dicho que la
acción va a bajar en relación a esta
esto es un poco más complicado porque
intuitivamente es un cortocircuito
disminuido pero si tus acciones las
tienes en corto y aquí no tenemos que
poner nada de dinero por adelantado
porque el contrato solo nos prestó las
acciones al momento y después podríamos
vender por 50 dólares pero la realidad
es que tienes que poner cierto capital
por adelantado pues la posición corta
puede manejarse en contra usualmente
tienes que poner el 50% del valor de la
posición corta así que en nuestro
escenario tendrías que poner al menos 25
dólares por adelantado y después pedir
prestada las acciones y venderlas por 50
dólares luego socialmente ustedes dos
tienen 75 dólares para jugarlos y
tendrían que eventualmente usarlos para
comprar las acciones que pedimos
prestadas por adelantado y el capital
son 25 dólares y nos convienen que las
acciones bajen si el escenario de las
acciones baja a 20 dólares habrás hecho
30 dólares así que podrás comprar esas
acciones por 20
y después poder regresar se las al
poseedor pues pero manteniéndose en 50
dólares por toda la red y llegar a 21
así que existe 30 dólares por 25 dólares
entonces tu ganancia que hiciste son de
100 dólares y lo que hiciste es que al
principio 20 dólares y después otros 5
dólares y esto es el 120 por ciento de
ganancia déjame escribir lo que por el
120% se establecen aunque bueno por
supuesto en este escenario ganaste pues
el precio de las acciones está por
debajo y en términos de pérdidas aquí
cuando el precio de las acciones sube
sube a 80 dólares perdemos 30 dólares de
esta manera tendríamos un 120 por ciento
de pérdida por lo que una vez más ciento
veinte por ciento de pérdida pues es
importante para nosotros por lo que en
una posición corta lo mejor que puede
pasar para el tenedor es que las
acciones tiendan a cero y en este caso
puede que puedas volver a comprar por
nada lo que significa que puedes
guardarte tu 50 dólares así que en el
mejor posible escenario
puedes poner 25 dólares por adelantado y
después guardar tus 5
dólares que obtuviste de la venta de las
acciones prestadas puedes hacer 200 por
ciento de retorno en el peor de los
casos lo que nos deja ver que este es el
mejor escenario pues 200 por ciento de
ganancia en el caso esto será infinito
así que mucho cuidado con cometer un
error en posiciones cortas en opciones
de venta pues sólo tenemos que poner
cinco dólares por adelantado para
comprar la opción de venta y cuando la
acción baje a 20 dólares estaríamos
haciendo 15 dólares esto es un 300 por
ciento de ganancia y del otro lado de la
ecuación cuando la acción suba lo peor
que podríamos hacer es perder todo
nuestro dinero lo peor de los casos que
podríamos hacer es solo perder el 100%
finalmente tenemos el poder de
multiplicar el poder de multiplicar
nuestras ganancias esto es relativo pues
la posición corta tiende a irse hacia el
lado de las bajas para tener un poco de
protección